Shazam and Superman will appear on the
silver screen together in spring 2019
but it's probably not the Man of Steel
you know and love-- potential spoilers
forces a ahead we got this covered
claims that sources in the know say that
Superman will appear in Shazam the
upcoming Zachary Levi led DC superhero
flick
Shazam tells the story of a
fourteen-year-old orphan named Billy
Batson who meets a mystical wizard
obtains the powers of six different
immortal elders and earns the ability to
turn into an adult superhero whenever he
utters the word Shazam
okay Shazam
the movie looks like a cheery remedy to
the doom II gloomy DC extended universe
but with the Man of Steel reportedly
making an appearance in the movie
Shazam will also feel like it truly
belongs in that universe for better or
for worse but before any DC enthusiasts
start jumping for joy or creating Shazam
and Superman fan arts we have some
disappointing news the actor popping up
in Shazam may not be the Superman star
most people are familiar with we got
this covered claims citing anonymous
insiders that Henry Cavill won't be the
man playing the metropolis Marvel and
Shazam this is reportedly due to cavils
disinterest in returning to the role
which he first stepped into for 2013's
Man of Steel the outlet further
speculates that the quote ongoing
alleged difficulties between Warner
Brothers and DC film's executives and
cavil motivated the decision The
Hollywood Reporter previously reported
that cavil had allegedly cut ties with
Warner Brothers and was actively looking
for a way out of the DC EU and his role
as Superman Batman star Ben Affleck was
said to be doing the same
leaving the studio's without two of
their biggest superhero stars a Warner
Brothers spokesperson however later
claims we have a great relationship and
great respect for Henry Cavill that
continues to remain unchanged
additionally we have made no current
decisions regarding any upcoming
Superman films if cavil is indeed out of
the running
who will portray Superman alongside
Shazam well word is that Shazam is using
a body double of the same size and
stature as cavil and not including the
character's face in the scene how will
that work reportedly the sequence in
question sees Billy fulfilling his
foster brother Freddy's wish for Billy
to appear as Shazam at their
school proving that Freddie is friends
with a real-life superhero
just after Shazam walks into the room
Superman follows behind officially
making Freddie the coolest kid in school
cavil for his part tests kept pretty
quiet about his relationship status with
the DC EU he only broke his silence by
posting to Instagram shortly after The
Hollywood Reporter's story went live a
bizarre video of himself wearing a
Krypton lifting team shirts and holding
up an action figure of himself as
Superman while a dog barked version of
the Blue Danube played in the background
in other words no comment his manager
Danny Garcia then went on the record to
state that metaphorically speaking
the Superman cape is still in Capel's
closet saying Warner Brothers has been
and continues to be our partners as they
evolved the DC Universe fellow DC EU
actor Jason Momoa who made a splash in
his Aquaman solo movie in December has
also maintained that cavil is absolutely
not done playing Superman and then he is
definitely not leaving the DC he you so
perhaps cavil is tied up trying to
renegotiate terms of a potential new
contract with Warner Brothers or he's
attempting to secure producing credits
and the ability to sign off on directors
and writers for Superman films as
various reports have suggested he very
well could be playing a waiting game
standing firm and not stepping back into
his Clark Kent role until his requests
are met or maybe cavil actually does
appear in Shazam in a hilarious cameo
and all these insider reports are just a
smokescreen it's no Deadpool but Shazam
looks like it's game to pull off such a
stunt we'll all find out the truth about
Superman's appearance in Shazam when the
film opens in theaters on April 5th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite DC superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you